all right Metal Gear Solid 2 time and a
lot of people have asked me where they
can find the original two Metal Gear
games it's actually on the HD one that
came out for Xbox 360 ps3 PS Vita you
can find both the original Kojima Metal
Gear games on there so yeah knock
yourself out have fun now let's review
Metal Gear Solid 2
Metal Gear Solid 2 Sons of Liberty how
do I even start this this this game is a
mixed bag if ever there was one Metal
Gear Solid 2 starts out a couple years
after the Shadow Moses incident from
Metal Gear Solid 1 and I'm going to
recap a little bit and give some Metal
Gear Solid 1 spoilers so if you don't
want these spoilers like guess you can't
really watch this it's just Metal Gear
Solid 1 spoilers all right Metal Gear
Solid 1 we learned that liquid snake
looks just like Solid Snake because
liquid and solid snake are both
genetically identical they're both the
genetic sons of big boss it's a pretty
important plot point in the entire Metal
Gear Solid series and at the end of
Metal Gear Solid 1 revolver ocelot gets
away with everything he's talking on the
phone with someone and he's like yes my
covers intact no one knows who I really
am and you're like who are you evolved
er Ocelot I'm more intrigued than ever
then you find out there was actually a
third son of big boss solidus who's
actually the president yeah president of
the United States and the whole shadow
moses incident alright now we're all
caught up
enter Metal Gear Solid 2 now it's been a
couple years since revolver ocelot got
away with all of Metal Gear Rex's dummy
warhead data that information and
got out there and now every company
military country dot-com has a metal
gear that they're working on yes Google
has a metal gear how do I know because
they have cars that drive themselves
yeah they have metal gear and now the
Marine Corps has made a metal gear to
fight metal gears this is Metal Gear RAY
an anti Metal Gear Metal Gear so it's
being transported on this oil tanker
Solid Snake jumps on the oil tanker
you're like yeah so it snakes back and
all the promos were like I yeah Solid
Snake's back go on the tanker stop the
new Metal Gear and it was all awesome
but in the back of your mind you're like
how can they make an entire Metal Gear
Solid game just on one oil tanker you
should listen to yourself the Solid
Snake segment in that oil tanker that's
pretty much the beginning of the game
then the hits the fan the tanker
sinks it's a big deal it's a big ol oil
mess because today Okajima can read the
future apparently then enter the biggest
bait and switch in video game history
two years after that incident you now
play as a character named ridin and
you're like who is this guy this is
gonna be for a few minutes right I'm
gonna play as him for a little bit and
then go back to snake nope you play is
riding for the entire game you play as
riding on this thing called big shell it
was a big cleanup facility that was put
where the oil
Aker Sankey nose kind of an
environmental thing and now a terrorist
organization called the Sons of Liberty
have taken it over
led by solidus snake hey you get to
finally see this third son guy now
playing as a new character that's not
Solid Snake wouldn't be so bad if they
just promoted it like that they didn't
let you know that there were bigger
things going on they didn't let you know
that you were going to play as a
different character so naturally people
were pissed they were like I played
through Metal Gear Solid five thousand
times now you're telling me I have to be
this other guy who's not half as cool as
snake even though you play as riding for
the entire game you do meet a guy that
looks suspiciously like Solid Snake
lieutenant junior grade Uruguay Plissken
yeah he's totally snake I do like the
fact that snake is part of your support
team but you missed the guy man you're
like I you're seeing them right in front
of you you're seeing someone that you
should be playing ads that's how you
feel you don't care about the fact that
he's grown a mullet since the last time
you saw him you want to be in granted
right and has a pretty cool story tied
in with him but it takes the entire game
and then the next two Metal Gear Solid's
to really reflect back and go yeah
ridings all right as for the gameplay
aspect of this game this gameplay was
insane it really stepped it up in every
way possible
again you can aim certain limbs on guys
bodies you can shoot him in the arm
shoot him in the foot you can hold them
up you know be like free sneak and shake
them down for rations if they don't give
you rations shoot him in the foot
they'll probably give you more I did
that a lot I was holding dudes up for
hours shooting him in the hand I guess
it's like the digital equivalent of
picking wings off of flies and I'm sure
it's not normal for you no but I did it
and I had fun again just like Metal Gear
Solid 1 these elements are commonplace
now but back then it was like all right
it's like Hideo Kojima was like all
right we're making a new Metal Gear
Solid game we're going to create it in a
way that every other game developer has
to look back and be like we gotta be at
least as good as that if we want to be
relevant anymore like when you're
shooting wine bottles off the wine rack
it's not that you can shoot the bottles
but specifically where you aim on that
bottle determines how it breaks that
was out of control in 2001 however
in my opinion this is the toughest of
the Metal Gear Solid games because it
was like they were like alright yeah we
have aiming mode so you're getting an
advantage so we have to make it harder
which means if you get seen and it goes
into red alert mode again you die I do
the fact that you know in Metal Gear
Solid 1 someone sees you it's like Brant
red mode you turn around 5000 guys just
wasting you with ak-47 but in this game
if someone sees you he has to call for
help before he gets back up so you can
blast him in the head shoot out his
radio choke him out snap his neck do
whatever as long as you can kill him
before he gets the word out helps not
going to come I like that element a lot
that was really cool doesn't change the
fact that if he does get the word out
you're dead and all of the Metal Gear
Solid games ever made I died the most
and Metal Gear Solid 2 whether it be
from falling off of a Ledge to a stupid
little camera that's floating in the air
that sees me that calls in the cavalry
two moments where it has that type of
Megaman trial-and-error thing going on
you know you're like oh there's a window
there I got seen now I'm dead
alright let's duck under the window and
go by it
alright sneaking under the window while
I'm crouching oh the floor just gave out
under me
just drop me into the water now I'm dead
I'm really gonna throw those curve balls
at me and make me die now the floors
gonna give out on you it was
however if we're gonna talk about the
villain in this game solidus alright
solidus is actually quite badass I'm not
sure I'm buying the fact that dude was
President of the United States and
people seem to like who are you I mean
like George W Bush coming up and being
like no I'm solidus so this snake give
you a snake bite you know won't they
and I'll be like who are you the
solidus is quite cool and you see in the
game you're like alright you're another
son of big boss but you're clearly older
than Solid Snake and liquid snake were
so eyed what's the deal and in the later
games they explained and I'll explain it
right now is that solidus snake was
actually the only son of big boss who
was an exact duplicate he was a clone of
big boss that's why he looks just like
big boss you don't really know where
revolver ocelots coming from you're like
I already know you've been playing both
sides before what side are you playing
for now again I like characters like
that one of the things you see him do on
the tankers he just wastes one of his
allies you're like talk to me goose no
don't talk to me I like not knowing that
however you're feeling about Metal
Gear Solid 2 goes from all right I'm
playing this right and then the plot
just gets strange even on the tanker
also it's like I'm taking it back for
the Patriots this dude's like the lolly
Lulu you're like who are the
and what are the what I guess I can say
in Metal Gear Solid 2 everything was
just more extreme from gameplay to
dialogue to plot to weirdness like you
know a Metal Gear Solid 1 Ocelot got his
arm sliced off now he has a new arm the
new arm is from liquid snake's body
so whenever Solid Snake is near him
liquid snakes soul possesses ocelots
body and he becomes liquid snake now
again with that supernatural element
that's always really been in Metal Gear
Solid to an extent god willing I ever
meet a real psychic in my life maybe he
can make himself float maybe I have to
switch my controller port I don't know
I've never met one but I have known
people who have had transplants and
those people do not get possessed by the
souls of people whose body parts they
now have that's just how I see it really
now they will explain this element in
the games to come but for right now as
you're playing - you're like that's
strange the weird character in Metal
Gear Solid 2 just had me scratching my
head was vamp he's more or less a
vampire yeah a vampire has been thrown
into the Metal Gear Solid mix I found
that so strange I can take a floating
psychic in the last game apparently but
vamp was just it was just so out of left
field I was like explain please and they
don't explain him whatsoever now like
ocelots arm and the whole possession
thing they're going to explain vamp and
a later Metal Gear Solid game but for
right now they're just like oh yeah
here's a vampire in the mix deal with
that weirdness that made me think that
Metal Gear Solid 2 was on such a strange
plane from wine that one seems so normal
in comparison then you play Metal Gear
Solid 3 and the bosses in there are so
strange that you realize that the weird
thing isn't the fact that they have a
vampire and Metal Gear Solid 2 the weird
thing is actually that the bosses of
Metal Gear Solid 1 are more normal than
they should be before you know that
though just throwing a vampire into the
military game it's just over it's a
really strange thing I would say that's
the thing that weighs Metal Gear Solid 2
down it introduces so much weirdness
into the series I doesn't explain it yet
it's a bit culture shock ish for you
nothing more perplexing than the end of
the game my friends you're playing the
game you're going along and then in the
course of about an hour's worth the
gameplay give or take you get this bomb
dropped on your lap that's not one bomb
it's just layers upon layers upon layers
of just continual revelation things go
from weird to strange - strange you
leave the game pretty much going what
the Metal Gear Solid 1 did a good
but establishing the world that would be
the Metal Gear Solid series but it also
existed as an isolated game that you can
play through and be like oh yeah that's
the plot of my one game Metal Gear Solid
2 really exists as the introduction to
the world that would become bigger it
exists to establish what the big picture
is what the problem is and what you're
fighting for in Metal Gear Solid 4 now
as a person who's played through the
Metal Gear Solid series I look back on
Metal Gear Solid 2 I reflect and I'm
like okay I get it
when the Metal Gear Solid saga is done
Metal Gear Solid 2 makes perfect sense
you look back on it and you go yo yeah
it's a completely relevant chapter and
it is absolutely necessary however when
you leave the game playing it in 2001
for the first time you're like that was
not Metal Gear Solid 1 and I do have to
give Hideo Kojima credit you know he was
like alright in order for this thing to
be a big picture at this point in time
you need to play as a different
character than Solid Snake that takes
balls to have your fans feel like you
just bait-and-switch them and then have
this game leave the fans with so many
questions that aren't really going to be
answered for about seven years the
themes at the end of the game touches on
when it just stacks you with information
overload and in the course of about 30
minutes our really cool themes it has to
do with censorship control control of
information control of human beings
corruption it's really cool it's like
g'day Okajima saw how the technological
era was making us and he came up with a
story that would be a really cool story
as to what the end game might be for
this and I like it now in 2012 being a
guy who played through the Metal Gear
Solid saga in 2008 however when the
newest chapter of Metal Gear Solid is
Metal Gear Solid 2 and you play through
it for the first time in 2001 you don't
really see it that way you just leave
going what what are the Patriots what
are the Lali Lou lay low because also
one of the major things is when you're
playing Metal Gear Solid 2 for the first
time you're like I'll solidus he's a bad
guy but if you play the game kind of
seen from the point of view of although
he's extreme he might not be wrong the
game gets a little more interesting and
makes a lot more sense
I can guarantee you there are people out
there who played through Metal Gear
Solid 2 and they're like I'm done with
Metal Gear Solid it's just too weird now
I would say pick up the series play
three and four go back and play - it
will make sense and it actually will be
really cool one of the cool things to
happen in Metal Gear Solid 2 was Harry
gregson-williams did the score he would
then
doing all the music to the Metal Gear
Solid games after that but him doing the
Metal Gear Solid music with that Metal
Gear Solid theme it's awesome that's all
I can say is him being added to the
Metal Gear Solid mix just made it
complete I look at your solitude does
have as insignificant is this is going
to sound it has one of my favorite
moments and this is scene where snake
and Otto Kahn do this secret bro
handshake and then they give five and
then they pull each other in and give
each other a bro hug that was what I was
like holy Hal Emmerich Otto Kahn is
actually a friend of solid snake snake
always kind of struck me as this guy's
like I don't have the luxury of friends
kind of guys you know he's the soldier
he's here to do what's necessary but at
that moment I was like he has a friend
and his name is Hal Emmerich aka Otto
Kahn I love that scene it's just so
humanizing for snakes
so Metal Gear Solid 2 stepped up the
gameplay stepped up the graphics was
technologically advanced to no end for
its time anyway looks great in HD if you
want to pick up the HD collection you're
like oh yeah it is like it's 60 frames a
second it's in HD it looks really good
however is riddled with really
frustrating moments when you get seen
when that thing goes to red alert you're
like alright I'm done I'm dead I could
try to hide in the locker but how many
times have you had the guy be like mmhmm
I'm gonna open this locker someone might
be in it the ending was really confusing
and kind of bizarre
however after completing the saga you
look back on it you're like okay yeah it
was all completely relevant and it all
makes sense
so Metal Gear Solid 2 what did you think
of it I'm really curious because
everyone I met when they first played it
hated it so have you played it recently
have you beaten the saga did you go back
and play it I want to know what you
think so comment below let me know and
as always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you